let's not kid ourselves we already all
know that the last Jedi is going to melt
your brain when it appears in theaters
in December 2017 after the force awakens
revitalized the Star Wars franchise at
the movies in 2015 there was little
doubt that the follow-up would probably
be pretty amazing
but now that we've gotten our first real
look at the movie via the debut teaser
trailer we can say with some certainty
that episode 8 will take us places we
never even knew we wanted to go here are
just a few of the reasons why Star Wars
the last Jedi will blow you away in
December Rian Johnson's sci-fi cred when
it comes to Hollywood's current crop of
go-to directors last jedi director ryan
johnson may not necessarily be a name
that everyone recognizes immediately but
ask any fan of johnson and they'll tell
you he's been helming incredible flicks
with consistent regularity for years for
example if you haven't checked out
2012's looper written and directed by
Johnson
do yourself a favor and make sure you
watch it as soon as possible
Johnson took a relatively low budget and
produce one of the more memorable and
impressive science-fiction movies in
years
just imagine what he can pull off with
the might of Disney's wallet backing him
up
lots of Luke one of the chief complaints
about the force awakens was that Luke
Skywalker the hero at the center of the
first Star Wars trilogy was pretty much
absent for the entire movie right up
until the very end
the lack of Luke makes sense in the
context the film of course since finding
him is one of the movie's main
objectives but some fans couldn't help
but be disappointed that one of the
franchise's most important characters
was barely there now though Skywalker's
truly back the new movie seems to have
no shortage of the former farm boy in
this trailer alone he presides over some
lightsaber training hangs out with r2d2
and even chills near the mouth of the
cave in short fans are going to be up to
their armpits in Luke Skywalker and that
fantastic beard of his if you love Luke
and you obviously do your prayers have
finally been answered captain phasma's
returned when fans weren't wondering why
there wasn't more Luke in the force
awakens
they were probably complaining that
Gwendoline Christie was painfully under
used as the shiniest stormtrooper of the
mall captain phasma she yelled at Finn
doctor boss that one time
got dumped into a trash compactor what
that really be all we got out of the
captain as it turns out no it wouldn't
we only see her for a moment in the new
trailer but unless the first order has
started handing out shiny stormtrooper
outfits to anyone who asks
that's phasma what she's doing in the
last Jedi of course is totally unknown
but it's good to know she's back ray of
light or dark in a revelation that
should surprise exactly no one the last
Jedi will finally start to answer some
of the questions about Rey that fans
have been asking since she first showed
up in the force awakens speaking during
the 2017 installment of Star Wars
Celebration actress Daisy Ridley said
simply what I can say is in the last
Jedi we go deeper into Ray's story he
was always a given that the hints of
Rey's origins and destiny we saw in the
previous movie would get more
exploration in the follow-up now that
she's been training with Luke Skywalker
she may make some discoveries about
herself and where she really came from
that could shock her and fans to the
core
speaking of which shades of Empire
Strikes Back
it's an oft-repeated truism but you
could never say it too many times the
Empire Strikes Back is the best
installment in the Star Wars saga so
it's exciting to see that the last Jedi
seems to be going in a similar direction
need proof there's a moment in the new
trailer where a bunch of ships are
speeding toward a confrontation with a
marching battalion of walkers just like
what happened on Hoth during the first
active Empire Strikes Back then there's
this serious struggle our heroes will
have to endure and overcome another
hallmark of Empire take for instance the
scene where Poe Dameron and bb-8 are
racing towards their x-wing only to
recoil from explosion now remember how
Luke got his x-wing stuck in the mud on
Dagobah or how the Millennium Falcon's
hyperdrive just kept malfunctioning we
only have the barest threads of the last
Jedi's plot to speculate with but it
seems like this new movie aims to echo
mini fans favorite Star Wars movie in
plenty of ways hello rose while ray is
sequestered away as luke student Finn
and Poe will need another ally while she
doesn't seem to appear in the trailer
Rose will be the new character to take
on that role variety reports that
actress kelly marie tran will appear in
the last
I as a maintenance worker in the
resistance who joined Finn as he gets
into his latest round of galactic
hijinks outside of that we don't know a
whole lot about ros though johnson did
say this at Star Wars Celebration she's
not a soldier she's not looking to be a
hero and she gets pulled a very big way
into an adventure in this movie with
Finn as to what else we can expect from
ROS in the last Jedi it's way too soon
to tell but it's pretty exciting to know
that there's a whole new major character
coming that didn't even make it into the
trailer imagine what other surprises and
twists were left out farewell princess
despite the excitement that comes with a
new Star Wars movie it's hard to forget
that actress Carrie Fisher passed away
in late 2016 leaving a hole at the very
heart of the saga itself we know that
Fisher finished building her scenes for
episode 8 before she died and we catch a
glimpse of Leia in the new trailer as
well chances seem good that the last
Jedi will provide a fitting farewell for
giving grieving fans some closure on one
of cinema's most iconic characters one
of Hollywood's most beloved actresses
delivering on the titles promised
towards the end of the trailer
Luke offers a cryptic confession saying
only he knows one truth time to the Jedi
to end while fans have been speculating
about the movie title significant since
it was first announced the trailer seems
to be giving us a definitive idea about
what it'll mean the Jedi as we've known
them aren't going to be reborn with Rey
rather their time is coming to an end
it's also important to keep in mind that
not everyone who practiced the light
side of the force was a Jedi as little
Maz Kanata can attest and let's also not
forget that the Jedi weren't necessarily
like super awesome you know
the Jedi Council shortsightedness and
rigidity helped turn Anakin Skywalker
into Darth Vader
while allowing the Emperor to take over
the Republic and Luke's attempts to
start a new bunch of Jedi led to Ben
solo turning his back on his family and
becoming kylo Ren suffice it to say the
end of the Jedi might not be such a bad
thing
here's some money go see a Star Wars
thanks for watching click on the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this other cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]